y
[Música]
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de la
entrevista de france 24 en español en
esta oportunidad nos acompaña salma
hayek si el embajador de haití en
colombia con él vamos a abordar cuál es
hoy por hoy el escenario que vive haití
que es el país más pobre de américa y
que ha estado marcado durante décadas
por la inequidad la violencia y también
desastres que han dejado múltiples
catástrofes naturales señor llamaría xxi
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24
muchas gracias señor periodista santiago
gracias a la entrevista
france24 gracias a usted y a los
auditores de france 24 que nos están
siguiendo en este momento así es gracias
a usted una vez más señor embajador
bueno quiera preguntarle en primer lugar
para cuándo podemos esperar elecciones
presidenciales y también parlamentarias
en haití y sé que hubo diálogos no entre
representantes del gobierno de la
oposición en este momento si hay un
diálogo entre los diferentes actores
para que haya
elecciones lo más pronto aquí posible
creo que no pasa un año para que haya
elecciones bueno muy esperanzador esto
que el gobierno 2023 estas 2 - 23 el
gobierno actual está trabajando en este
tema hablemos ahora vamos a ir
recorriendo algunos puntos que quizás
son críticos no para haití uno de ellos
tiene que ver con la violencia verdad de
hecho según la oficina integrada de
naciones unidas en haití voy a citar
algunas cifras los enfrentamientos sobre
todo entre bandas armadas no en puerto
príncipe la capital dejaron
188 muertos 120 heridos 12 desaparecidos
tan sólo entre abril y mayo hay diálogos
abiertos entre el gobierno y actores de
esta crisis para uno de los problemas
más difíciles que tenemos actual en
haití es el tema de la violencia de las
bandas armadas en
haití en si está dividiendo en cuatro
partes para ir hacia el sur es un
problema para ir hacia el norte es un
problema para el hasta este oeste
también es problema porque hay grupos en
diferentes lugares para circular pues el
tema de secuestro en tema de matanza así
las cifras que usted menciona ahorita
así es
y bueno vamos a hablar ahora última
también muy importante que tiene que ver
con esta crisis y otras sobre la que
hablaremos luego que tiene que ver con
el rol de la comunidad internacional
verdad y aquí también voy a citar un
comunicado que lanzó la organización
estados americanos la oea no voy a leer
exactamente un fragmento de ese
comunicado en el que afirmaban que la
crisis en haití es resultado directo de
las acciones de las fuerzas endógenas
del país y también de la comunidad
internacional cuya presencia de 20 años
en este país fue uno de los fracasos más
fuertes y manifiestos que se haya
implementado en materia de cooperación
internacional esto estuvo en un
comunicado de la organización de estados
américanos como le decía cree que ha
habido una suerte de abandono por parte
de la comunidad internacional o quizás
perdón planteó otro escenario cierta
distancia no entre los pronunciamientos
y las acciones concretas bueno si
empezamos a revisar durante los últimos
40 años la presencia de la comunidad
internacional estaba en haití
siempre ha escuchado pues volúmenes de
plata pues que se invierte en el país el
resultado está en lo que estamos
viviendo hoy en día por lo cual creo que
no podemos seguir pues con la misma
política de la misma forma de
interactuar no ya con diferentes
personas estamos hablando para
interactuar totalmente diferente la
política que se venía aplicando
anteriormente no funciona la crisis si
es endógena no entonces hoy en día los
jóvenes hay muchos sectores que
entienden que el país no puede seguir de
esta manera y seguramente pues que
pensando de la manera que la comunidad
internacional no espera durar en dos
tres cuatro años se puede ver el cambio
porque el pueblo haitiano en sí eso
el pueblo de siguiente no y
pues rápido podemos salir de esas
situaciones habla usted de una necesidad
de cambio cuál sería el cambio
fundamental por parte de la actitud de
la comunidad internacional el cambio
sería acompañarlos digamos para
construir en sociedad para construir las
instituciones no porque sin
instituciones no hay absolutamente nada
la presencia de ellos allá si es
importante pero tan pronto no es tan que
pasa pero si nos ayudan a construir base
el duradero y sostenible hacia el tiempo
y la presencia de la organización de
naciones unidas en particular qué
evaluación hace usted
bueno todos los organismos
internacionales que nos han acompañado
durante todo el tiempo
nos damos cuenta pues del resultado la
idea es central con ellos hoy en día y
repensar la forma de ayudar a haití y
vuelvo un poquito la pregunta anterior
que esta forma de reformular no la
manera en pensar a haití tiene que ver
con un cambio vinculado a esto que
muchas veces se suele manifestar bajo la
expresión que se hace mucho ruido y
pocas nueces' no hablar mucho decir
mucho hablar sobre la necesidad de
ayudar pero a la hora de los hechos no
tantas medidas si es interactuar e
interactuar acompañándonos hoy en día
pues por ejemplo en colombia hay muchas
experiencias que yo están haciendo con
diferentes instituciones no el mismo
gobierno colombiano como ellos quieren
rural no no es imponer sino acompañar el
tema de transferencia de conocimiento
ayudar por ejemplo tenemos la policía
educar a la policía acá no
nosotros tenemos ya en haití un problema
pues de de conocimiento técnico
tecnológico
cómo podemos hacer triangulación no los
grandes alcaldes organismos pueden plata
los países en vías de desarrollo nos
ayudan con un conocimiento así viceversa
y seguramente en pronto las cosas pueden
cambiar en una suerte de
retroalimentación está planteando por lo
que veo hablemos de otro tema que tiene
que ver con la crisis alimentaria que no
afecta sólo hay te afecta a muchísimos
países del mundo sobre todo hoy en día
no es una crisis
y ahora voy a citar otro informe es un
informe de la fao no la versión de la
onu para la alimentación y la
agricultura que señala que en haití más
del 80% de la población no tiene acceso
a alimentos 147 puntos 2 por ciento
estaría sufriendo de malnutrición
empeoró todo lo que es seguridad
alimentaria a partir de la crisis en
ucrania que como decíamos ha expandido
esta crisis y este conflicto a lo largo
de todo el mundo claro
si revisamos durante los últimos cuatro
años hemos tenido un problema político
además no el problema político tiene de
percusión económico y seguramente la
población está afectada más ahora con la
crisis internacional este hacia el
resultado si los números son ciertos
pues la idea es
volver pues hay otra cosa para no estar
pensando solamente en tema d
los básicos que debe de tener una
sociedad para vivir es el alimento no
leemos ahora de emigración irregular una
crisis migratoria que viene hoy en día
todo el continente americano
involucra a muchísimos ciudadanos
haitianos muchos de hecho intentan
escapar del país por vía marítima y son
muchísimos los que pierden su vida en
esta travesía no como encara el gobierno
haitiano esta crisis
respecto a eso hay algo que yo quiero
explicarles a todos para que sepan la
crisis en migratoria haitiana en américa
latina no son haitianos que salen
directamente de haití para la región
94 con el mundial del brasil
brasil se cruzaba mucho mano de obras
haitianas
aproximadamente unos 2 millones de
haitianos
trabajaba para el mundial en brasil
chile en 2010 después del terremoto nos
ayuda también
disfrutando pues haitianos para estudio
y para trabajar
más o menos unos 800 mil haitianos en
chile hoy en día con la crisis que hay
en el mundo y con el cambio de gobierno
que había en eeuu
los haitianos que estaban en esos países
salen para
están los sonidos pero no son haitianos
pues que salían directamente de haití
para cruzar toda la región sin embargo
pues sí en bahamas por ejemplo hay casos
o hacia república dominicana si hay
bastante
haitiano que se está migrando
buscando oportunidades hablaba usted es
precisamente bueno de esta mano de obra
haitiana que se utiliza en muchísimos
países mencionaba chile-brasil entre
muchos otros y también se utiliza en
república dominicana no un país que está
realizando está concretando un proyecto
bastante polémico no que es la
construcción de un muro fronterizo algo
muy criticado por organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos
porque argumentan que provocará lo que
podría provocar xenofobia racismo
coincide cuál es su evaluación sobre
este proceso bueno pues yo creo que en
este aspecto cada país
interactuar tienes el libre albedrío
para interactuar en este momento
nosotros en haití estamos trabajando
para el cambio
no me pongo mucho a analizar pues porque
lo hacen porque no
dejaban de hacerlo yo me concentro más
que todo pues en haití a ver cómo
podemos hacer para resucitarla para
innovar para porque el pueblo haitiano
si podemos entonces vamos a solucionar
los problemas que está pasando en haití
en este momento llamaría exile se nos
acabó el tiempo se pasa rapidísimo
muchísimas gracias gracias por invitarme
muy amable gracias a todos no gracias a
ustedes de una vez más a nuestra
audiencia como siempre la invitamos a
que sigan informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación y también por
supuesto en france24 punto com sigan
junto a nosotros
[Música]